Tinh common array methods I'm going to
go over some of the most commonly used
array methods in JavaScript the first
one is going to be arrayed is pushed the
push method this just adds a new element
to the end of an array and if I console
that lock that you can see now it's ABCD
and you can see that started off as just
ABC the next one I want to show you is
the pop pop removes the last element in
an array and returns that element now
run that we're going to see we have the
D and then if I just cancel that log the
array again you will see that now the
array doesn't have that the D on there
because it's been popped off the push
and pop changes the original array the
next one is concat which concatenates
two arrays first I have to make a new
array so the first array and K at array
two if I run that we're going to see ABC
G Q one thing interesting about that is
that it does not affect the original
array so if I just console.log the
second array we'll see that it's still
GQ the next one I'm gonna go over is its
join this joins all the elements in an
array to create a string and also does
not modify the original array so if we
run that you can see at the end we just
have the string ABC and if we put
something I joined this with just a an
empty string but I can also put
something in here like an exclamation
point and run them and you can see now
there's an exclamation point between
each item in the array and that string
and the original array stays the same
next up is reverse what just reverses
the elements in an array
if I run that you can see at the bottom
CBA and that does change the change
their array so if I console that loggia
right now you can see at the NCBA cba
the shift function is going to remove
the first Elm in the array in return
that element so the first Elm is C
because we reversed an earlier before we
reverse that array to CBA now with
returning that first element C and if we
just consult that log that array again
we will see that it is a C is removed so
if you look at the bottom just going to
be a for the array unchipped adds a new
element to the beginning of your right
and returns the length of the modified
array so at the end it's just going to
say 3 because remember before the array
was BA
so this is or add the p2n to make 3
elements in the array so if we just log
that array we'll see P be a and the P at
the beginning of the array slice is
going to select part of an array in
return that you already you've selected
in the original array remains unchanged
slice is going to accept two arguments
the start and the end minus 1 let me
give you an example so it's going to
start at the index 1 and then the second
argument is the end minus 1 2 minus 1 is
V 1 so this only give me one character
of the array because you always because
this it's this minus 1 for the end
character let me cancel that log bake so
you can see that this is the original
appa
and we're going to start at index 1
starts index 0 then we have index 1 and
then we're going to end at the index 2
minus 1 0 1 2 minus 1 so we can end at
the same character that we started at so
it's only going to return B so change
the second argument to 3
then it's going to be PA instead of a
and slice does not change the original
array so the original array is still
going to be PPA now I'm going to show
you sort was just sort an array so first
I'm going to push a few more letters
onto the array if you see at the end a
BF IP so that's all sort of even though
you can see that I add F at the end in
depth sorting internet first it was PBA
this is what the array started off as
because this like Winston slice is
something it's not going to change the
original array so it we had this and we
added a F and then it's sorted to be
like that and you can see that sort does
change the original array the last one
I'm going to tell you about is splice
splice is very similar to slice but it's
going to modify the original array
instead of just returning a new array
also the arguments are going to be a
little different
the first argument is going to be the
start index also as to the second
argument is the number of items to count
from the starting point to remove so if
I put two that means two items are going
to be removed
starting at the set the second index I
put 3 even 3 NH will be removed and then
the third argument is any items you want
to add so I'm going to add Jace Nuggets
and it's going to return the items that
were removed and then I'm going to log
the array so if you can see first it
removes fi because it started off with
this array and we went to this index 2
if we have 0 1 2 we remove 2 items 1 2
F&I and that's what it returns for this
first console log and then we're going
to console dot log the new array which
is B a B J's nuggets because it's going
to insert it at the index that we had up
here which is the second index and we're
still gonna have the P on here well
thanks for watching my name is Bo Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good